welcome to this video playing ray 1 I
think it's one yeah was this real ray
one I guess okay let's try the
fianchetto again against the Kings
Indian I'm trying to play a player
aerosol it set up Quincy so it's that
some somewhat wow I thought the somewhat
passive way to play but maybe he really
wants to wants to play it with with f5
maybe let's let's consider f 57 i th for
not clear should I go d5 here or not
it's probably not bad now the gunite h4
scott bishop f6 maybe it does not not
really help me okay maybe prepare before
long term
yeah five is slightly we go I'm El
platform okay so f4 set up this this
block and I'd show up you're going to
play efore maybe you for Bishop e3 or
Bishop f1 maybe wow that's a very
uncommon move in this type of this type
of structure attacking the porner on b3
if I play play be on c4 ever play b3 he
will take a 4mm funny cannot really take
five Bishop take some Bishop takes us
slightly annoying hmm
might be six strange but interesting
that's not I mean why i love the plague
we need to i thought i should protect it
somehow maybe he's going for Bishop f 6m
Stern trying to take care okay going to
regroup here the bishop on f1 to protect
see form yeah somehow this is an awkward
position not sure what I did wrong here
hmm up like a sony okay we can even
consider to take one c3 the Sun this
type of move Bishop takes III was played
in a famous game i think by Petrosian
check okay i want to go there anyway
okay shown here 93 maybe I can play this
night see to an idea trying to to
exchange this song night b5 is also
coming into consideration yeah it
definitely is maybe even this an ID c 2
next before also a six i have
ninety-seven probably and then before
the capture is not very good i guess but
i can do here I always have night night
six if he decides to decides to attack
this
the strange position definitely okay we
decided to take it so I thought okay
let's let's just take here first and he
they also have night see to hear night c
2 nite centuries if the bishop moves to
f6 I can play Bishop a 5 which is quite
nice Bishop c5 I can take take b6 yeah I
think I'm okay again I think it's a
slightly weird position of course and
now I have this smooth
so Bishop to g4 on 94 I guess Bishop um
this is a big big bishop on one f6 here
to take g3 m-maybe protect it from the
side should be too I want to prepare
Bishop e2
he's not threatening to take on on c4
it's that's a that's a pin
threatening bishop age five now it's not
so clear to me what he should do now
yeah maybe this but certainly not check
not something that I'm very much afraid
of time warning came just take here now
yes now 93 m centralizing looking
protecting and everything Queen g7 is
this coming maybe I have root g one
though I no no no no no no no and I gy
it's it's also taking the Queen need to
do this stupid move not ideal
a sick sick from this very nice position
check check check check just 11 seconds
my ass looks at you at the end I know my
winning streak is ending from a
completely winning position is ah what a
shame white resides yeah round here of
course blackest black is completely
outplayed but I couldn't I couldn't wrap
it up okay the computer is not so
optimistic just 0.67 for me I thought
that black is basically busted here but
it does not seem to be that clear okay
tails takes computer just what wants to
grab the pawn maybe this is this is
right but it's still just 0.7 10.5 I it
gets down now yeah maybe I'm a queen g7
was a was a shocking move for me that
was really a that chief I I didn't see
Nyjah for I thought before I can just
play rook rook g1 but of course not g4
and then then before of course mother
was a strong move ook c7 I can just take
g3 yeah he missed a mate in 2 a.m. well
ok yeah I was totally shocked I was
totally shocked by Queen g7
rook c8 assessors we are done Jack a
young I'm struggling Jack and only
blundered this these pawns but like is
this is still better yeah so why did I
that did I this was a weird game in any
case it isn't this year just just good
for white it seems that Queen Queen d2
is the solution okay hmm why what is so
much stronger about that bishop here
then I can go here and I still have this
this threat no this is the threat so he
cannot go to go here and Knight a5 also
hang so yeah okay I had the suspicion
that there should be something with what
I played was okay but nothing oh he
could have played night a4 wow black is
clearly better computer stuff
I got this at the end we at game really
okay well thanks for watching